las elecciones avanzan con tranquilidad
acá en washington hoy sábado 9 de abril
en todo el continente americano y en el
caribe se llevan a cabo estas votaciones
presidenciales en francia y en el resto
del mundo las elecciones presidenciales
serán el 10 de abril las urnas en
washington se abrieron desde las 8 de la
mañana y cerrarán a las 7 de la noche y
hasta el momento el ambiente es de
tranquilidad los ciudadanos franceses
acá en eeuu en washington tuvieron que
haberse inscrito en sus respectivos
consulados o por internet antes del 4 de
marzo para poder votar en estas
elecciones presidenciales de lo
contrario podrían hacerlo a través de un
apoderado que fuera a votar en la misma
circunscripción en la que estaba
registrado el ciudadano francés en el
exterior hay que mencionar que hay cerca
de 280 mil ciudadanos franceses viviendo
en norteamérica y hay 10 consulados
franceses principales en las ciudades
más importantes de este país que
habilitaron docenas de centros de
votación para que los franceses votarán
hoy